a reminder of our breaking news in the
last few minutes the first minister of
wales mark drakeford has announced a ban
on anyone
living in a covid19 high-risk area in
england from entering wales that travel
ban applies to those living in both tier
two and three areas let's have a listen
to what he had to say
i have therefore asked for the necessary
work to be brought forward
which would allow for devolved powers to
be used
to pro to prevent people from traveling
into wales
from high prevalence areas of the united
kingdom
this isn't an issue with regards to the
border between wales and
england that's not the point here as
adam bryce
said now it's a matter of fairness in
terms of what we've
done here in wales and what we've asked
the prime minister to do
in england so that's why i've written
once again
to the prime minister the timetable
for the powers that we have in wales is
to do it by the end of the week
that gives more time for the prime
minister
of the uk government to
do the things that we have asked him
to do